The first epic trailer for the Captain Underpants
movie just dropped and as it's based on the
best-selling book series, the movie looks
like it will be packed with easter eggs and
references to the original novels by Dav Pilkey.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and in this video, I'll be revealing some
cool easter eggs and other interesting details
you might have missed in the first full Captain
Underpants movie trailer.
So let's start with pranksters George and
Harold are creating comics in a treehouse,
and you'll see that in the middle of the floor
is the brand name they use for their comics,
"Treehouse Comix Inc".
There's also a Robo-Boogers easter egg on
one of the comic book covers we see in the
treehouse.
The Robo-Boogers are monsters which appear
in the "Bionic Booger Boy" books of the Captain
Underpants series and, as you might expect
from their name, they are technological creations
based on snot.
And there's another clever hint to the Robo-Boogers
later in the trailer via the Snotco sign on
the building that Captain Underpants runs
along.
Ok, let's get to Captain Underpants himself
as the trailer reveals how George and Harold
transform their mean Principal Krupp.
George uses a Hypno Ring to hypnotise Krupp
and make him think he's the Captain Underpants
character from their comic books.
This transformation is similar to the first
Captain Underpants book where George and Harold
use a Hypno Ring to hypnotise Krupp when they
want to recover a videotape the principal
is using to blackmail them into performing
chores for him.
In the movie though, it looks like George
and Harold use it to stop Krupp putting them
in separate classes.
After Krupp's been hypnotised, George snaps
his fingers presumably because he thinks this
will snap Krupp out of his state.
However the snap kicks off Krupp's transformation.
In the books, whenever someone snaps their
fingers, Krupp automatically turns into Captain
Underpants.
And in the trailer, after his transformation,
he delivers his classic catchphrase, "Tra-la-laaa!"
Mr Krupp aka Captain Underpants is voiced
by actor Ed Helms, who was one of the stars
of The Hangover movies.
So, I wonder if George and Harold's prank
with the tiger could be a hint to the first
Hangover movie where Ed Helms sings a song
about a tiger that appears as part of a prank
in his hotel room in Las Vegas.
While Captain Underpants is battling a giant
inflatable ape, in the city skyline you can
see a billboard for "John's House of Toilets",
a building which appears in Part 2 of the
"Bionic Booger Boy" books.
In that story, Captain Underpants stands on
top of "John's House of Toilets" where he
performs the Underpants dance to annoy and
bait the Robo-Boogers.
Next up in the trailer, we get to meet Professor
P, who stresses, rather amusingly, that he's
not the evil villain of the story.
Professor P's full name is "Professor Pippy
Pee-Pee Poopypants" and the character was
introduced in the fourth Captain Underpants
book.
And if you feel like you recognise Professor
P's voice from another recent animation, that's
because it's Nick Kroll, the voice of the
all-singing, all-dancing pig Gunter in the
animated movie, Sing.
And Professor P is clearly controlling this
giant toilet character who is likely Turbo
Toilet 2000, the leader of The Talking Toilets
from the second Captain Underpants book "Attack
of the Talking Toilets".
Talking of toilets, it looks like George and
Harold played a prank on classmate Melvin
while he's demonstrating some kind of toilet
invention.
Melvin's toilet invention is clearly going
haywire and this might be the prank which
got George and Harold into so much trouble
with principal Krupp.
Melvin is the nemesis of George and Harold
in the "Attack of the Talking Toilets" book
where he invents the PATSY 2000, a photocopier
that can convert any 2D-image into a real
object.
And in this other shot, it looks like Melvin
is teaming up with the nefarious Professor
P.
Interestingly, in "Attack of the Talking Toilets",
it was Melvin's PATSY 2000 invention which
was responsible for the creation of the Talking
Toilets, so I wonder if, in this movie, Melvin
and Professor P will be the ones responsible
for creating Turbo Toilet?
When Captain Underpants takes out two bank
robbers at Frank's Bank, it's a nod to the
very first crime he stopped in the first novel,
although in that book it's because the robbers
couldn't stop laughing after he told them
to surrender or he'd use "wedgie power" on
them!
And finally, did you spot the amusing store
called "Everything Except Fabric Softener:
The Store For All Your Non-Fabric Softening
Needs"?!
Well, it's a location that appears in a number
of the novels and, as the name suggests, it
sells almost everything, but definitely not
fabric softener!
So, what did you think of the first Captain
Underpants trailer?!
Let me know in the comments below!
And if you enjoyed this, I really appreciate
you hitting that like button and why not subscribe
for more easter egg and animation videos?!
And you can also check out some more videos
you might like right here.
Thanks for watching and see you next time!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!